bouda aime jouer aux mannequins pour
essayer les créations de sa maîtresse
mais il devra patienter pour de nouveaux
modèles car yasmina azam qui
confectionne ses articles vient de
reconvertir sa micro entreprise
je voyais qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'engouement mon frère qui me disait
fait démasquer des masques des amis
aussi qu'ils voulaient que genre en face
fait que je me sens moi je serai
commencer puis on verra
elle s'est donc mise à produire des
masques à la maison environ 25 par jour
j'ai regardé différence tauriel pour
trouver une seule hantise d'un masque
celui laquelle j'ai choisi à valeur
quand même si populaire
elle a choisi le modèle avec cordon plus
confortable que les élastiques derrière
les oreilles
surtout quand on le porte longtemps
selon elle c'est plus long à produire et
les clients doivent être patients mais
le filon est très prometteur j'ai jamais
fait d'autant plus que les ventes aussi
ont explosé pour ces deux créatrices de
mode qui ont mis de côté leurs
collections pour produire avec leur
couturière près de 700 masques par jour
une des causes de leur succès françois
legault la journée qui est arrivé au
point de presse avec son masque qui dit
que le port du masque était recommandé
le kilo comme officialisé en 30 minutes
les limaces que je venais de mettre en
ligne étaient tous vendus
l'entreprise a dû embaucher du personnel
juste pour s'occuper des commandes à
envoyer aux milliers de clients
si on acceptait toutes les commandes
pourraient prélivraison jusqu'en 2030
les entrepreneurs ont évidemment dû
apprendre à créer ce morceau de tissu
peu conventionnel avant la pandémie
yves la manipulation d'une petite broche
insérée dans la couture fausse y
retourner pour sa phase des beaux coins
faut bien plié bien retourner bien
s'être pressés si créer de toutes pièces
un masque fut somme toute relativement
facile pour ces designers pour ses trois
amis issus du milieu de la construction
et de l'immobilier
la courbe d'apprentissage fut plus
complexe nous autres ça a été une
progression exponentielle à partie de la
journée
cette semaine on a environ dix mille
commandes par semaine qui qui rentrent
en moyens d'accès c'est énorme
avec toute une structure de vente sur
internet bien aller a reçu des commandes
pour 75 mille masques
un succès qui les a forcés à
s'approvisionner en partie en dehors du
québec élastique coton à montréal
extrêmement difficile à avoir sommé en
ce moment donc pour ce concert revivre
nos partenaires corée mais l'objectif
demeure toujours le même c'est d'avoir
un produit qui fait à montréal
en attendant une production la plus
local possible
ils partagent une partie de leurs
bénéfices avec la communauté
on reste dans les masques on va pas bien
d'autres domaines mais on veut offrir
aussi un soutien à différents organismes
qui nationale
anne marie laflamme apprécié ces
nouveaux produits mais s'ennuie aussi de
ses propres créations de mode il ya
beaucoup de charge émotionnelle qui est
plus lourde que lorsqu'on veut une
europe par exemple
donc ça c'est sûr que ça nous demande
plus d'énergie puis aussi l'urgence
d'avoir le produit puis l'anxiété que ça
crie c'est quand même du seul à gérer
donc retourner à nos produits qui sont
plus positifs et légers dont je pense
que ça à un moment donné ça vanne
fatigués pour yasmina âmes employé dans
une garderie pour animaux la culture du
masque instauré par la pandémie est là
pour rester et cela fait rêver pour
l'avenir si je pouvais vivre demain
petite boutique qui ne plus travailler à
temps pays je serais vraiment une
maîtresse qui travaillent à temps plein
à domicile
c'est comme un rêve aussi pour bouddha
ici frédéric arnould radio-canada mort